welcome to this video yeah this is our
cool Lea corner frequent opponent let's
see what's going on yeah last game I did
not upload it was a winning five movies
or something where the opponent it seems
had to leave and just resigned the game
yeah he offered a couple of drawers but
I declined it's not a very fair player
in terms of playing on time and stuff
like that so I didn't I didn't just take
the draw usually I do with this I mean
it can happen here you start a game and
then something's coming up and if I feel
they are fair players I normally just
take the draw but not against people who
play on rook against Lucan time and
stuff like that and this was one of the
guys not old I guess another another one
okay we have a good two Queen c2 names
oh and hmm he's playing it in a somewhat
peculiar way I'm not sure if this is a
correct way to describe it hmm edit it
it's all mo it looks like in a bit like
an head shock but not not quiet
there's some way to exploit this as kind
of a weird situation here I don't know
how come on let's let's be quick here
for once it looks kind of wrong this
kind of knight c6 the whole thing
I mean 96 and the giving position is
normal but the whole combination of
moves looks a bit strange I have 95 but
I'm not sure if it leads to anything
substantial - might just be a big big
trade
I don't know it just it just it might
not lead to anything a bit unsure I
think he has to take with the pawn it's
it's pretty clear but I'm not even sure
how I recapture I'm sorry
Edie Edie Edie is not working right I
was thinking he takes the five as
possible I have to check with the C pawn
of course okay and I will get back get
back the piece like that yeah it is
probably quite good now because he does
not have a great way to recapture how
does he how to see recapture now
I mean Bishop takes us well a six is
hanging or not or not I can just take a
six year round or is Bishop before good
I also have Eve five but if five is not
as convincing Bishop a six Bishop before
is this cheek it's not completely clear
not quite sure why ever it's not
completely clear
it's kinda weird bishop here hmm
there's some way to win material here
it's hard to believe it looks so wrong
all this Queen somewhere and Queenie to
Bishop f6 is hard to say like here and I
have two ins I cannot calculate this in
this time okay a Bishop f6 Bishop f3
Bishop f6 Bishop f3
I can the Bishop down here maybe should
f6 Bishop f3 Queen f3 Bishop f6 yeah but
this is not really that convincing yeah
I'm better but it's not so great really
isn't that great I don't know I have to
play this is intending Bishop f6 and
Queenie for of course and if he moves it
back in 7 hangs yeah okay 90 how the
thing is of course the time we know the
deal
mmm that's a really bad position for
black but one minute 14 c6 is a gaping
hole and while Bishop on e4 has just
just completely misplaced
now it's very good for my butt but as
you as you can see the time is a huge
problem
Oh didn't see that more coming with a
door
96 I guess rooks is six time warning
okay
I really didn't play it while right
seems like he's got got some kind of
coordination him which you really
shouldn't have a green age five forget
about it
what am I doing here this is just insane
this is really frustrating
I mean how bad do you want to play this
was just completely off what did I do in
this game here what did I do
check nice is completely winning here of
course queen of three wins God Oh help
I mean this is this is not easy I mean
what I managed she is to screw up the
position after d5 after d5 this is just
absolutely terrible public yeah this is
a tote this is a hole 94 this is just ah
what did I screw that up not easy just I
mean I just have to control this
position a little bit and have you
really played probably the worst
possible sequence of moves that wasn't
blundering stuff out right so he gets to
e5 this is the first step to screw it up
probably maybe should be three the
problem why this is so bad for like yes
I have a perfect locate of the pawn
those squares are weak I mean any
endgame if you remove the Queens from
the board this is just like the total
disaster yeah I just play f3 Bishop g6
back and I'm completely controlling the
position two against one on the Queen
side b6 is weak and so on this is very
one-sided the only thing I have to avoid
is to sort of I mean what I did yeah
just just completely screwing things up
96 is still winning here but I mean this
is just I mean how can I love how can I
do this yeah allowing Knight g4 is it's
just terribly bad I mean yeah I can just
do this and and and I'm winning or what
yeah
probably am right at least wins in
exchange it's very difficult for him to
avoid it
this kind of thing I mean yeah it's
useless yeah okay this is 96 is
especially terrible yeah I mean it queen
h5 of course it's that's the idea
I still can't play Bishop d7 it seems
and hold on I mean this is not I mean
not good but at least I don't need to to
give it up immediately but yeah I'm
still sort of playing it's not brilliant
but it's still still a game yeah after
this there is there is no game wow
that's really bad yeah it sort of it is
a problem if you have haven't played for
one week I always some do stupid things
but this is especially bad okay well
thanks for watching anyway